it obviously required a huge amount of
political courage and Leadership and
this is a question we've asked
um John Major and Bertie hurt which is
there was a lot of leap of faith
um in order to get over the line and I
think we all fall into the Trap don't we
presuming that there was an
inevitability of getting it over the
line it wasn't until the 59th minute of
the of the 11th Hour those of us who
sort of followed it closely remember do
you do you think in this sort of social
media
driven age which looks to
Echo Chambers and so on and so forth
that it could have been delivered
then but that bravery and Leadership and
courage have been
trimmed
I'm so grateful that social media wasn't
a big factor I think that's answered
that question right it's a it's it's a
frankly I mean it's got many good things
about it but it's a plague of modern
politics sure sure it makes life really
difficult but I think the only way that
you can you can lead in these
circumstances is just to put it to one
side and so I think look it was still a
very charged atmosphere but and and it
may be that you know when we came to
office
um
you know it was the
there was a great first splash of
enthusiasm I don't
mean
necessary for the people to the
government but the government felt that
it had well things could only get better
we won't joining the chorus of it but uh
no
probably not the best thing to do
um but
um so we we had a key ambition
and it may be because when you come in
as a new government you're you're
feeling of possibilities is greater than
when you you carry on over time you
become a little more realistic about
things and and frankly it did require
um an almost unrealistic sense of
possibility in order to get the thing
back together again but it really even
right into going into the Good Friday
agreement negotiation
I mean the thing had actually collapsed
on the eve of that negotiation because
it became clear that whatever had been
agreed in principle by the British and
Irish officials uh with Senator Mitchell
was unacceptable to to unionism when I
got to
um to Belfast that that day it was
absolutely apparent that unless we
essentially started again that we were
not going to get an agreement so I I
think and even throughout those those
days of the negotiation I would say
it came together and collapsed several
times before we eventually reached an
agreement and in the in the run-up to it
what there was was an appetite to have
an agreement that was the the only thing
that kept me going and I think kept the
team going during that time was that you
could definitely feel that people wanted
it to happen
um and I think that was the difference
from previous years and was and was that
local politicians responding to
a pressure from the from from Grassroots
across Northern Ireland or was it
leadership telling people that they
should
it was a bit of people that had enough
it was a bit of both people were
exhausted by the conflict it was
apparent that as it were neither side
nor the commons could could win
um and so the only
solution was either to continue with
with what had been the
the situation in Northern Ireland which
was obviously terrible
um for the people there and and for the
whole of the
um the United Kingdom or you could try
and strive to reach an agreement but I
do think there was also
there was a new generation of leaders
yeah and
I think it's important to emphasize as a
as a as a lesson of this whole process
that it could never have happened
without real leadership being exercised
by the political parties
and each of them
had to say things to their own followers
that were uncomfortable that people
didn't like and that is the true Mark of
leadership in the end because any fool
can tell the people that support you
what they want to hear it's when you're
telling them what they don't want to
hear that that's the test of leadership
is is
is forged and
you know David Trimble was the leader of
the unions Community I mean David was a
absolutely devoted unionist but believed
that time had come to try and reach
agreement the shin Fein leadership were
in a different position from the
position they'd been in in previous
years
um Seamus Mallon the sdlp it's worth
saying they were they were people who
took a lot of risks for peace then there
were you know the parties that are now
more significant like the alliance party
and so on the women's Coalition they
were also agitating for a
a a new
um
a new Direction
and even though the dup at the time were
opposed to the agreement
I think they were
opposed to it that willing to wait and
see how things turned out and you know
it's worth recording that Ian Paisley
also
um showed leadership when he finally
took the the European to government so I
think
um
yeah there was a there was a different
generation of leaders and it is very
important to understand that the the
teacher at the time bertia Hern was also
a different type of leader yes who was
interested in a
good relationship between the British
and the Irish she wasn't really he
wasn't he was
obviously came from the history and and
his
lineage was very much dominated by the
history of the conflict but he was
prepared to think differently cool
one of your predecessors uh said the
worst thing in or being a prime minister
was events Dear Boy events
and we know that
sure your first government or first
Ministry was obviously dominated by a
lot of constitutional reform setting up
the Welsh assembly the Scottish
Parliament and obviously everything that
flowed from The Good Friday agreement
conflagration in the uh Middle East
obviously took up a huge amount of HMG
bandwidth
was that
a a negative distraction as it were
because
I I did the support from Westminster
through the Belfast
to make sure that the show was kept on
the road it clearly needed greater
nurturing than Cardiff and and Edinburgh
and there seemed to be two big questions
which
certainly other commentators appear to
have suggested may have been envisaged
to be sorted out in 2000 2001 2002.
Legacy
and
um a fleshing out of the criteria
or the the male may not lead to a border
Pole
is that a fair assessment are there
things that you saw would have been more
immediate in that process which had
begun by The Good Friday agreement which
then got
derailed because of larger events and
looking back is that a disappointment
no I would really say it it
once we got the the Good Friday stroke
Belfast agreement up and running and in
place
preserving it became a vital priority of
the government and so I don't I didn't
you know yes of course the the events
Post 9 11 were hugely important and took
up a lot of time but they never
displaced Northern Ireland as a priority
and I think you know the record would
show that I continued both engaging with
the issue personally making visits you
know we used to have these weekends away
where we would try and resolve thorny
issues now it was always going to be a
top priority for us and some of the
issues because the Good Friday agreement
it it was a framework which then a whole
lot of other things had to happen
but all of those things were difficult
and you know to this day they remain
difficult even after you know the events
of 9 11 of a long past as it were so no
I I don't think if people are saying we
were distracted afterwards no we weren't
we
so is there anything you
I know kick yourself about that you go
I just wish whilst we had that sort of
new enthusiastic momentum I just wish
we'd sorted out
this that or the other
um
you know we were always trying to sort
things out but the problem is it's
you had to get things in a certain state
of Readiness because you know the thing
about a a conflict such as this
is that the levels of distrust are very
deep
and the levels of distrust are not
displaced by the agreement by the way
really yeah
it wasn't that people did the agreement
and then they shook hands and said okay
we're all friends now no the distrust
continued
and therefore if you take an issue like
decommissioning
which
you know is an incredibly difficult
question
right
um
there was never any way you were going
to have a sustainable executive unless
the IRA gave up violence and gave it up
completely
on the other hand because of what they
believed they had been through
they were constantly thinking you're
going to get us to to give up this um
struggle but not actually make the
changes on policing or criminal justice
or the things that are on the other side
of the Ledger and likewise with Universe
they would say look
we're going to make all these
concessions of change
but you're going to allow the IRA to
carry on being the same violent
organization so there were levels of
distrust
between the parties and there were
levels of distrust aimed at the UK
government and you know that's
that's the way it is and it probably
continues in the same way today in terms
of the breaks as one of your successors
might have said
Robert
yes um so Tony I want to ask you about
the underpinning elements of the
European Convention of Human Rights and
the human rights act as part of the Good
Friday agreement much debate currently
about whether or not the Human Rights
Act needs reform there's a Bill of
Rights that's currently before the House
of Commons it doesn't seem to be
emerging from the long grass
particularly but it is a different way
of approaching human rights do you think
that amendments or reforms to the Human
Rights Act
will help or hinder the process of
Northern Ireland
um yeah I think this has got a some
Dimensions that are broader than the
issue we're under discussion
look
my view is it's the
the European convention human rights is
important it's an important obligation
of the country and I understand all the
frustrations dealing with it I had a lot
of frustrations myself
um but I still think it's an important
part of the
of
um
it's it's a it's an important part of
the the structure that that holds up
the the agreement and the and and the
sense that the
there is always recourse to something
fundamental when judging
um individual actions or situations so
you know I wouldn't
be in favor of myself of changing it in
relation to the agreement though
thank you
okay thank you very much
it's very nice to see you sir Tony I
don't think my backseat ever met until
perhaps a day and face-to-face so it's a
pleasure although obviously even a big
play a big part of playing in the
Affairs of Northern Ireland and we uh
respect that and understand that
every mindful Mr chairman of the uh of
that sound bait that the hand of history
is on your shoulder Dr Pearson and
probably the Martin McGinnis as well
um
the hand of History was on their
shoulder and I think uh calculated that
very well
it's very important of course that they
Belfast and Good Friday agreement move
forward in a in a suitable way we as a
party in the up I was part of the
assembly from 1988 right through to 2010
before it came here
I recognized through Dr Perez's
leadership as I think he did as well and
through the leadership of Mark McGinnis
that there was two people with very very
different point of views that were
coming together to to push forward a
democratic process that could
encapsulated the type of use of both
traditions in Northern Ireland so I
recognized that as well I supported Dr
pierzyna at that time
but most of the party did and those that
didn't perhaps
fell in behind as time progresses has
seen the the positives of it
but the point I want to make up account
please my doctor Paisley and Martin
McGinnis from different parts of the
community recognize that they they um
Belfast on Good Friday agreement or the
sudanes agreement as we had them that
took it to the next stage was a way
forward
um I think you recognized
I perceived didn't recognize uh that and
for what you've said so far it's very
clear that he that he did uh that the
political process could never go
anywhere unless two communities at least
uh brought together a process and the
assembly was that process to move
forward so we're looking forward to
today your thoughts upon where we are
um and and the process and and how they
um Belfast Good Friday sent down these
agreement has moved where it is now to
them
they want our framework
um we're very conscious and I've seen
your comments in the in the paper uh so
Tony how much did you refer to Guardia
Hearn your third and both yourself and
Bernie Hearn to architects of the of the
political process as we move forward
um said that nothing can happen within
the The Windsor framework uh or with any
agreement going forward if unionism
isn't part of that process I think it
recognized that our way way back in
those early days so looking forward
um to today is it your opinion uh that
that the involvement of unionism and and
I represent a large section of unionism
as was my colleague here Carl Lockhart
as well we cannot move forward unless
the unionism is part of that process
ever mindful of what you've done what
are they earned on what Dr Petty done
and ultimately with Martin against them
yeah it showed him yeah you knew this
has got to be part of the process it's
uh the whole basis of the
of the agreement is that the the
different elements in in the politics of
Northern Ireland come together and and
that cross community
um
working together that's that's of the
essence of the agreement I mean
obviously I hope unionism can you know I
mean we can talk about the Northern
Ireland protocol I'm very happy to but
but of course you know as a matter of
principal unionism has got to be
as has got to be involved otherwise it
won't work yeah you mentioned in your
just yes you mentioned that um tutorial
and your comments
I think it's a realism that you had
where where you you looked at the both
political parties and you and just
taking your introductory Words which I'm
I'm seating upon them if I can where you
said that they um
the parties have to go back although we
did not agree with it at that time go
back to 1980 but the parties had to
agree on something to move forward
um
is there not really a realism or has to
be a realism in today in in the
political process in in Northern Ireland
your words were a realism or start again
I think I have to be a realism with the
Windsor framework or or start again
yeah that that there has to be a a
realism but I think
I mean to go straight to the point Jim
on the on the The Windsor agreement and
the and the protocol
the problem is we're trying to reconcile
um
you know the inevitable
two different elements that come from
from from brexit and its impact on on
Northern Ireland
so you know once you
for the first time you you end up with a
a situation where the Republic of
Ireland and the United Kingdom are in a
different relation to Europe and in a
different relationship to its Customs
Union single Market
then the border between North and South
in in in on the island of Ireland
becomes the the frontier between the EU
and the UK and
um so inevitably there is there is a
problem because you want them the border
to be open that's always how it's been
and and the one point of the consensus
amongst all the parties in Northern
Ireland is keep the border between North
and South open quite rightly
um because that makes life easier for
for everyone but once that border then
becomes the external border of the EU
you you've got a problem because you're
not in the same
relationship with the Customs Union and
the single market and the the idea was
to ensure that Northern Ireland retained
the benefits of being in the single
Market keep the Border open but that
then leads the European Union to say
well yeah but how do we then manage the
rules of the single market so it was
always going to be a difficult Circle to
square
um and the protocol is a and the Windsor
agreement or attempt to square it so I
think the question is but the realism is
that there is no real
answer to this problem because I mean
you know just to see when John Major and
I went to Northern Ireland during the
course of the referendum we said this is
going to be a problem because it
obviously was going to be a problem
there's no I don't think there's no
theoretical answer to it there is a
practical answer and my reason for
supporting what the government this
prime minister has done on on the
Windsor agreement is that I think it
represents
the most practical way forward that
minimizes all the theoretical objections
it doesn't remove them but it means that
they're going to be practically should
be in most circumstances practically and
significant and and that is honestly
what the best I think you can do with
this I appreciate your answer but uh I
want to make sure that the one-time
framework does not pick up the words
thank you very much indeed
um
we mentioned at the top of the session
um the lack of inevitability of Landing
The Good Friday agreement
25 years old do you think there's a
there's sufficient public knowledge
particularly amongst younger people of
both the significance of the event and
do you think that there's an
underpricing of the dividend that peace
actually is
yes yes I mean I think
um you know it's only natural life moves
on and that's one of the great things
about it that life does move on and
people don't think about it in the same
way but when I was
growing up in politics as it were I mean
every day the news will be full of
um stories of fresh acts of terrorism
assassination
um conflict it was a it was a very ugly
and difficult situation that people
lived through in Northern Ireland and
and you know you you you barely went a
week in the UK without it leading the
news and virtually always in a negative
in a negative way and I think you know
if you look at Northern Ireland today
it's GDP I think is virtually doubled
it's very Capital Income has virtually
doubled the number of people coming
through his airport has doubled through
the number of tourists is more than
doubled so it's some Belfast is a if I
could use it in this context it's a
great European city today and recognizes
such you know it's a great great place
so no I think there is a it's it's
natural but there is an insufficient
recognition and there's also I think a
an insufficient
recognition of the importance therefore
of keeping this going because it's
I think
one thing that I did underestimate is
that I always thought it would be a
process that would take time
but
I think
the difference with Northern Ireland and
most peace processes and I've had a lot
to do with the israeli-palestinian
continent
and
one difference in favor of
the resolution of the
israeli-palestinian conflict is that in
in theory at least there is an agreement
as to the
the the the the final outcome which is a
two-state solution now it's
come well of course plainly but if you
were to ask people in the International
Community they would say okay but we
know where we want to get to it's just
that it seems impossible to get to it
but with the Northern Ireland conflict
we've never resolved the central
question United Island the United
Kingdom and therefore the the in a way
part of the
in the outstanding result of of the
agreement was absent that agreement as
to the eventual outcome and an agreement
that people would disagree as to what
the ultimate solution would be there was
nonetheless the opportunity to bring
peace and we did that by by there was a
an intellectual framework at the heart
of the agreement which is an in essence
the acceptance by republicanism and
nationalism of the principle of consent
the Northern Ireland would remain part
of the UK for as long as the majority of
people wanted it and in return for that
the creation of Institutions that people
in felt were just and and would resolve
some of the feelings of Injustice and
would also reflect and this is where the
Strand two and strand three were
important that the agreement would
reflect the Nationalist aspirations of a
um of
well almost half of the community
Northern Ireland so it there was that
there was a construct around the
agreement that had its own coherence and
we would never have succeeded without
that
but
implementing each of the stages of this
was agonizing and it is
it's it's
disappointing that we're still you know
we're still dealing with many of those
issues and that distrust is deep and by
the way you can tell the distress
because
you know every time you hear a
politician including myself speak about
the Good Friday agreement occasionally
particularly when you've got an eye on
the unionist audience you call it a
Belfast agreement and then we try and
resolve that by saying well it's a good
Friday stroke Belfast agreement or a
Belfast but that is an indication if
you're in Dairy London Dairy it gets
entirely confusing yeah so it's you know
it is it's a that's the way it is
um but it's still a world better
you know whatever the problems in
Northern Ireland what people should
never forget it's a world better from
where it was and if we exercise common
sense and realism today we can keep the
peace intact and
you know ensure there is a situation
where whatever difficulties and
challenges there are in Northern Ireland
can be resolved by negotiation and
agreement not violence I mean have you
got any thoughts I mean you know you
were
often sort of scene is one of the great
sort of political communicators of
recent jokes but have you got any
thoughts about how that message
can be distilled and indeed received by
a younger audience in Northern Ireland
but that sort of scaring them of the you
know Blood on the streets and the
crashing down of buildings and bombs and
so on and so forth
in order to
have a higher regard for the for the for
the peace dividend I mean I colleagues
are fed up with me saying this but if
you watch the last couple of episodes of
dairy girls for example there's that
wonderful Montage at the end where it
said where it shows the horror and then
it shows the huge enthusiasm and hope
and worry on the older Generations face
on referendum day itself and then the
joy and relief we've got something over
the line we've got something to work
with
what what if if you were in number 10
today what would you um and be
encouraging your government and the
leaders of the parties in Northern
Ireland to do to build that
understanding of don't risk slipping
back well first of all I think I would
focus a lot on economic and social
progress and the need to do more there
are still communities in in Northern
Ireland that are severely disadvantaged
and wherever there is
the alienation from the mainstream of
people feel they don't have hope and
opportunity economically and socially
there's there's always going to be the
it's a fertile ground for those people
who want to lure them into to violence
but the second thing I think is to
you know
it's
so so if you look at
Northern Ireland today and and you know
I still follow closely what happens I
don't
go because it's probably not sensible
for me to start I don't want to ever
seem to interfere and it's hard enough
your successor to do the job without
um
previous person on an issue censored of
the Northern Ireland telling telling
what should happen but I
I mean I
okay I am I'm a unionist by the way I
mean I
you know my preferred outcome is that
Northern Ireland stays in the Union
um
so but there's a new message there's
there's a new member of the totally
Blair fan
clubs I'm probably about to say
something that's going to to lose my
legs all right okay don't like to check
at you well I know
since I don't have a lot of them it's
um dissuade those that are but so here's
basically the way I see the politics in
Northern Ireland how it's developed is
that
republicanism in the end decided to
change its strategy
now you can agree with whether you think
they're sincere or not sincerely even
have all those agreements disagreements
but essentially they came to the
conclusion
that the armed struggle was not going to
yield what they thought
now leave aside the fact that we believe
that moral they should have been engaged
in it but they came to the view
politically it wasn't going to succeed
and so they've shifted their strategy
and even though it's posed a lot of
problems the politically actually for
the sdlp who were there a long time
before
it's been I think you would have to say
from their own
point of view quite a successful
political strategy right
I completely understand
I think an hope where unionism comes
from and I always say to people you know
one of my earliest memories around
Northern Ireland was my
grandmother
saying to me there's a great Beacon of
Hope in Northern Ireland his name's Ian
Paisley and you know this was get the
checkbook out with him no this was so I
was always
you know I was brought up very much
within a unionist
household
and I understand
that
the fear of unionism
is that everything is a slippery slope
right you're basically always if you if
you
if you accept
the types of compromises that are in the
Good Friday agreement if you accept
British Irish relationships who accept
north south and what you you're always
going to be sliding towards that United
Island
and
that strategy I don't think has really
changed over the years
learned about it it's always been like
that and that's why even though I said
it's quite honestly even though we're at
one level
it was always strange for unionism or
any part of unionism to support brexit
because it would plainly put the the
issues of Northern Ireland at a diff
difficult context on the other hand
I kind of accept for the same reason
that a lot of people
in my old constituency voted breaks it
some people thought mistakenly in my
view that the more British thing to do
was to vote brexit right and therefore
if you're part of unionism you kind of
think well why not
the thing is that strategy has not
really changed
but the third element that's come into
Northern Ireland politics in these last
years which I think is you know worth
thinking about
is is the alliance party has
risen right so it's not I don't know
what do you look at the polls it's like
15 or something round about that
um when I was uh prime minister I don't
think there was an alliance MP I think
the first one was 2010.
and if you look at the age range of
those photos I think that they'll be
probably in the in the middle in the
middle range right
and the alliance
probably predominantly they're a
unionist people
probably okay maybe not but
Stevenson
but the point is I'm not sure but but
the point is
if you want to preserve the union today
the best way of doing it
is to recognize the status quo is the
Union
so make people comfortable with the
status quo
because the more comfortable they are
and this is
I'm quite sure at the back of their mind
the risk the Republicans think of with
their political strategy is that people
are comfortable with the status quo by
changing
but if the status quo becomes subject to
constant disruption
and constant political difficulty
then that
middle-aged bulge that's there with the
alliance at the moment there's going to
be another one coming up in a younger
generation and then things are going to
get more difficult for the union and
that's why I'm
you know I support the positions I
support because I believe passionately
in the end the people of Northern
Ireland should decide their own future
but I come at it from the point of view
if someone you know I want my country to
stay strong
that's why I'm
I'm supposed to the SMP in Scotland and
oh why my preference is that Northern
Ireland remains part of the Union but it
can only be that way in my view
if people feel the status quo is
something stable
so this is where I think you know when
you you ask me what is the what do I
think about the politics now I think the
important thing is to get over this
problem of the protocol if at all
possible to get back into some
to to an agreement to reform the
executive get back into power
and then you know over time to deal with
these these issues but the less
stability there is in the system the
more it makes me anxious about the
future
sorry it's a long way of putting it no I
I'm I mean that's
given me a lot certainly given me a lot
to think about that sort of make the
status quo attractive
given given the emphasis you just put on
stability and we've had 25 years of the
devolved institutions but they've only
been functioning about 40 of that time
and you know as you'll know very well
there are various different reasons
um that have been given for the various
breakdowns that have taken place
um how big a disappointment is that and
um what do you think could be done
institutionally we've heard from other
Witnesses but you know the intention of
the agreement was always for the
institutions to evolve do you think
there's more Evolution that could have
happened to support stability
um
yeah it causes disappointing um
it's maybe less surprising given
all the challenges
I think the the
I would like to have seen strand tunes
and strand three more more vigorously
used
um
I think that
uh
you know the relationship between the
British and the Irish governments I mean
okay it's been it's been scratchy
recently but let's hope that's
resolved I mean ultimately it's
we've got a lot in common we can work
together I think yeah I I think we we
could do more to make those strands more
meaningful and and and more active
frankly
and and just I mean on that
the relationship between the governments
but also the relationship between London
and Belfast and and Devolution and that
was but how do you think
the nio over UK government uh can do
more to support for developer
institutions and support stability of
those without being seen as the
mothership without being seen to be
lying in wait to take over and I work
well remember periods in in the run-up
to ndna when at the nio we were having
to look at two tracks of work one about
how to get agreement and and bring the
party together and another thing about
what would happen if we didn't
um how can we avoid that situation
keeping on coming up I'm not sure you
can to be absolutely I think you'll
carry on and look the officials in the
Northern Ireland office they're they
come under a lot of criticism from all
sides but I mean they're basically
people trying to find
ways through the the difficulties but I
think the most the most important thing
is is to try and you know as the we've
had the government's done I mean you try
and resolve the issues over the protocol
try and get back to a devolved
government and then you know
it's it's one of these things you just
constantly got to keep on it
um and and it does require it does
require the time
um and and focus sometimes of the Prime
Minister and not just of the Secretary
of State
uh Robert Buckley must have come in a
quick one and then Mary well it's to
develop your well-made point about
associating the union with stability
absolutely plain as a bike staff to me
that the more the people in Northern
Ireland feel that membership the United
Kingdom equals good Public Services
stable institutions they're going to
want to stay
and that does beg the question about the
Saint Andrews agreement
um of the the Saint Andrews agreement
and the current way in which the
executive is formed I mean could an
answer be to go back to the status quo
before it's a dangerous agreement where
you have the the uh the cross the common
slate approach and the cross community
agreement which you know various times
various parties
have supported I mean there was one
point with the dups supported that
approach in order to prevent Shin vain
from coming into the executive but
obviously you know with the elections
and the change in the power structure we
know institutionalized this sort of you
know this
twin party approach and your point about
the change in politics in Northern
Ireland might be the alliance in one
election might be another
uh party or another group how do is that
is this not now getting in the way of
the very stability that we all want to
see
yeah
I got an awful feeling that the the
words to hunt principles might come in
we've had evidence which I I hope that
we never have to hear again
but I know the feeling yeah
I look I think
this is the the there's always a case
for for Change and there's a case for
change
particularly now with the the emergence
of the alliance party
um and
I think the North Belt fast
political action group of schools this
would be an interesting document the
other day which was set out how young
people view this but the truth of the
matter is as we discovered and what this
is why we did Saint Andrews you can only
do these things by agreement if if it's
not
the thing you can you can never do with
this situation is say right I'm just
going to decide what's right in
principle and I'm
I'm I'm just going to do it and I used
to be called constantly when I was
promised to just go and do it and
you just can't it's not you've got to
you've got to reach these changes by by
consensus
um
and and if you can't get that consensus
if one part of the community
feels that it's aimed this the changes
aimed at them or is reducing their
what they believe is their their
legitimate rights it's just
we won't get it done is my experience
which is
you know why I always used to say to
people on the Nationalist and Republican
side that the relationship between the
British government and unionism is much
more complicated than you think that was
sort of said to escape don't tell the
universe what to do I say have you met
these guys they're not going to just do
what the British government says right
so you're gonna have to persuade them
um and which is you know from that point
of view quite right
uh Mary Kelly Foy
and
um good morning
I
am a relatively easy one and could you
could you just tell us and you have
touched on it a bit what what it is
that's pleased
surprised and disappointed you most
about the Good Friday agreement
well the disappointment was obviously
the continuing stability
and
I'm not sure anything is much surprised
me
um but what's pleased me is the fact of
the agreement in it the piece is still
there it may seem fragile but I think it
is still there and I don't think there's
a
desire in any
part of the
community in Northern Ireland with any
substantial support to displace that
please
and you know when you look around the
world and and you know as I said I was
involved in the israeli-palestinian
still I'm actually in in that particular
issue you know you realize how difficult
it is
to to get any form of peace agreement so
we should celebrate the fact that we did
um and then we should use that
celebration as a reason for redoubling
efforts to preserve it
okay
um secondly you'll be aware of around
the the sensitivities and the debate
about the the Legacy issues what was it
that you envisaged
um on the on the subjective Legacy
you mean in relation to the victims the
troubles yeah well the Legacy bill
that's just gone through Parliament but
what were your intentions in terms of
our intentions were probably the same as
this government to try and find a a way
of resolving it but frankly we couldn't
and and and didn't then it remains
extremely difficult so I wish I I could
uh
I mean I think whoever grapples that is
going to find it really tough to do
it's the truth yeah and did you
anticipate that
that five years on would still see
paramilitaries
in the form of criminal gangs I think
you were that that it doesn't surprise
me that there are
there are groups that will try and
disturb the peace from time to time
um
what would disturb me is that I thought
they were starting to gain substantial
support now you need to watch this the
whole time watch it on the Republican
side watch it on the Loyola side
but I don't I mean
the other
Representatives here from North Island
will know better than me but I still
think that
the desire and the vast majority of
people is to resolve issues
issues peacefully
yeah
thank you thank you
just on the paranage who's 25 years on
huge efforts to transition
is there a cut-off point to the process
of transition
or does it get masked by this
Northern Irish exceptionalism argument
I mean I think
particularly when you start to get real
turbulence
you know over the process and and the
politics I think you're
you know you're going to find these
these groups
starting but it's important to remember
that they only managed to get traction
over the
over the situation when they had real
support within the community and I don't
think that support exists at the moment
but I'm not you know I'm not deep in the
detail of it today and and frankly be
better asking that of the Secretary of
State or indeed the members of
parliament representing all that
um
I've got Claire and then
Carla wants to come in and then Stephen
I'm coming to you thank you very much
certainly really enjoying your your
inputs today and just thinking back to
the early implementation years
um Jonathan Pyle your colleague said
recently in retrospect we should have
been willing to be a bit tougher and not
something that
um resonated with me do you think that
there was
um some damage to stay in to to the
culture and and the sense of trust
within the process and maybe a bit of
moral hazard in allowing deadlines to
slip
um in allowing parties to sort of talk
about the agreement but to do things
that were clearly in contravention to
the to the spirit of exclusively
peaceful and and Democratic means and
I'm thinking at this point about
decommissioning and not supporting
um the rule of law and do you think that
that was a factor in in part did that do
for uh David Trimble and his electoral
support and has that therefore had a had
a knock-on impact that the the main
party of unionism wasn't they they're
advocating for the agreement does that
contribute to some of the low levels of
support we have in unionism now
yeah well it's a very reasonable
question and one I I uh agonized over a
lot
um
and
you know I think
um
I made a speech once about the process
of ambiguity ending and acts of
completion being necessary and it came
to the point
whereas it were
you know
we we have to say to the IRA look it's
you've got to stop everything it's got
to be absolutely clear and not just the
the paramilitary violence but the
violence within the communities
and you know you could yeah you can make
the argument we should have done this
earlier but the problem was that we were
trying to manage a situation where
you were
trying to get to the right outcome but
always conscious of the fact that you
might lose
either unionism on one side
republicanism on the other side
I always
one of the things I found most difficult
and most troubling and I used to have
this debate a lot with Seamus Mallon
Sheamus used to say to me
you pay attention to
the Republicans because they got the
weapons and that's the very thing that's
contrary to the principle that you
should be trying to uphold and it's a
perfectly reasonable point
but as I used to say to him okay
Shameless but if you're prepared to go
into government
without them
and with the unions okay we can have a
conversation but you you know you you
can't really do that and so it was
always difficult
and you know I look I I uh
I understand from the sdo P point of
view because after all the
speaking from a moment as a member of
the labor party it's the sdlp that's our
sister party so I completely get it but
it the difficulty was
you can go in retrospect and say
um we should have been tougher but when
you were there at the time
you were trying to make sure that the
best wasn't the enemy of the good I mean
that's the honest answer
squeaky wheel yes the oil we would we
would sometimes say but did did and
build on Robert's question about the
changes it's in Andrews did you foresee
and I and I understand the points you're
making about dealing with the at the
moment as it was did you foresee the
polarization that would follow and and
rebel on for for these 20 years later of
of bringing I suppose those harder line
views into the center and I I appreciate
that maybe the logic was that it
prevented them from sort of screaming in
the windows and and thwarting the
implementation as they were doing but
had you stepped out the polarization
that would probably continue electorally
yeah so I think
my view this has always been that that
it it
I didn't
predict this but when I look back on it
I think
maybe it should it should have been
predictable that when you first begin
something completely new as this was
that both communities default to the
people they think are going to stand up
for them in inverted commas so Shin Fang
gain on the national side the DP gain on
the union side
now my view is if the stability
is there and continues over time
you know over time politics changes you
know over time the issues should be in
Northern Ireland who's gonna who's gonna
make the right reforms to make the
Health Service work better who's going
to do best on education who's going to
make sure that that you know communities
that are deprived are brought up
to to a better standard of life
whilst
the politics is dominated by the feeling
that the thing isn't really stabilized
and therefore you've got to stick with
your own the people as I say who in
inverted commas I'd put it in inverted
comments will stand up for your
community I think it's going to be
difficult but politics is a long game of
it and I do think you know the the rise
of the alliance party in this respect is
important you know because you you're
and it may be that in time the the you
know the stlp can find the right way
of improving its position that you see
this
you know it's you see this all over the
devolved politics of the UK
and it's a very look it's a very
sometimes I have people particularly on
the right who say to me look
as a result of devolution you know you
gave Scottish nationalism a big
boost right and I will say to them you
think Scottish nationalism was invented
by the last Labor government there were
decades before
if you hadn't we hadn't done the
evolution the choice in Scotland would
have been between a status quo with no
Devolution and Independence and in those
circumstances I can tell you over time
there would have been a real move for
Independence whereas I still think that
my viewers that Scotland will probably
in the end believe its best chance
remains with the UK but I think if you
hadn't done Devolution you would have
put that start Choice before people and
in the same way in in Northern Ireland
ultimately the benefit of the Northern
Ireland assembly should be in the long
term that people decide their own future
there and provided that the Border
doesn't become an obstacle
you know in the end I think people
people people will decide to fight the
politics of Northern Ireland around who
does best for the people not who as it
were again in the vertical Commerce
stands up for the people indeed and the
question was motivated about just
looking at those dynamics of
polarization rather than rather than
strict electoral outcomes thank you
thank you very much Stephen
chair and good morning sir Tony um oh
sorry I'm so sorry forgive me forgive me
I'm sorry terrible traffic
[Music]
thank you and uh nice to meet you uh
certainly thank you for your evidence
this morning
um we all have different memories of
that time and uh and around the 1998 and
one of the ones that probably
is vivid in my mind is your visit to
Korean and you're writing on the on the
on the Whiteboard and I wanted to just
crash on the back of Mary's uh question
around Legacy and
all that goes with that one of your
pledges was equality a fairness and
equality uh guaranteed for all and my
question would be how fair on victims of
terrorism were they on their own letters
to over 200 Ira fugitives this is the on
the runs yeah I think some years back
I've been in front of the committee and
went into this in detail I mean the
problem with the on the runs was very
very simple
that
might agree with it or not agree with it
but in the in in the Good Friday so
Belfast agreement
um
we essentially were releasing the people
who've been convicted
so these are people who'd actually be
convicted of Acts of terrorism
they're then naturally and over time
this group
came an issue as to what you do about
the people
that as it were have not been convicted
that might
might be right
and those divided into two categories
the ones that the police thought there
was insufficient evidence to judge and
the ones they thought that there would
be sufficient evidence and what we tried
to do was
obviously deal with the problem of the
people in respect of whom the police
decide there wasn't evidence to charge
them and it would be irrational
if
we were going after those people whilst
we'd actually release the people who'd
been convicted of terrorism so that was
what we were trying to to resolve and
you know again it was a very difficult
situation but we did the best we could
with it
a back room Dale and there was no uh it
wasn't written into any texts you know
was it was it that that ultimately
brought the IRA towards their Cesar
um
I don't think I think that was obviously
a big issue for them by the way it was
you know again I dealt with this when I
was in front of the committee those some
years back
I mean when people used to call it a
secret deal it was mentioned in
parliamentary answers and we were pretty
open about it that there was a problem
we had to deal with but I look
there are I think the most difficult
conversations I ever had with people uh
in the whole of the process were with
the victims
of the of the troubles because these
were decent
people
members rooms family are being killed or
maimed by terrorists and we were letting
them out of prison
and there's no I mean it's a very hard
conversation to have now
I can and I did justify it by saying we
needed to do this for the peace process
in order to give people a better future
in Northern Ireland I mean three and a
half thousand or more people died in the
in the troubles we wanted to make sure
that there weren't further deaths but I
agree it's always there is an element of
compromise there that is morally
uncomfortable and there's no there's no
way out of that but the releasing of
prisoners was was a well-known uh hour
on the dock the deal and obviously we
were utterly opposed to it utterly
opposed and but the on the runs was less
well known and ultimately we have
victims today who every time they see
and hear of these individuals who
receive the get out of jail free card
um you know re-traumatized by seeing
these individuals who
blatantly and many other things are I've
not been buying this drama but
glorifying terrorism and floundered in
the face of victims
yeah the problem is they didn't have a
get out of jail free cup because these
were the people in respect for whom the
police had said they didn't have
sufficient evidence to charge them so
the problem was you you were you were
always going to end up in a bizarre
situation where you were going after
those people having released people
who'd actually been convicted I mean
that was the problem we were trying to
deal with
um thank you chair and the good morning
sir Tony and just to put on record our
thanks for your efforts and reaching the
good friend agreement uh obviously we're
coming off the very important milestone
for the 25th anniversary and I was a
very Junior member of the alliance team
back in those days as well so it came
acrossing many times not in that
particular regard
um just wanted to ask you a bit more
detail around the issue of Reform of the
institutions
um when you're analysis of the Alaska
growth was was accurate in many ways
um did you see the institution has been
set in stone in perpetuity or it was a
expectation that they would evolve over
time in line with changing circumstances
and changing demographics and in
particular
did you see some potential pitfalls with
the system of community designations and
the relegation of
parties like ourselves to the other
category and do you see a particular as
a strong case for reform of that
Dimension to reflect the changes that
have clearly taken place over the past
25 years
yes absolutely there's a case for
there was a case for keeping I think the
agreement actually specifically provides
for a review and and yeah you should
always keep it under review
but it's got to evolution is the
is the key phrase because you've got to
do it with agreement
um and
yes I mean I think as as time goes on
there there will be a a growing sense
for change but I still don't think you
could make a change to this agreement
unless it's done consensually if you do
it and one part of the community feels
it's aimed against them then it'll be
problematic but I can understand the
frustrations from
Daylight's point of view
um
it's but it's just
and and as I say the agreement itself
provides for the possibility review but
I think it's it can only be done if if
the parties agree amongst themselves
it's going to make for a more effective
government and I think right now the
priorities got to be to stabilize the
existing situation
to get the
protocol
late to one side and to get the
institutions back up and running because
there's probably a very slightly
different aspect of Reform which is
around the use of of videos If a party
has a veto over
the current set of arrangements
are they likely to consensually agree to
give up that veto in terms of moving
towards a more uh sort of modern more
globalized system of government
particularly mindful that
um particularly changes have happened to
boundaries lock us into the situation of
this beauty contest this is which party
is the largest and other side but also
means the government can't be formed
unless both of the two doctors parties
can send to it and we've clearly had a
situation where
um a recent pasture in the film stopped
gotten from happening obviously being
here happening and people are very keen
to be away from that sort of a cycle of
of politics being held hostage
yeah I think it's a it's I can
completely understand the frustrations
people have and
you know the the concept of veto
it's got a it's got a kind of legal
meaning that's got a practical meaning
and the problem will will be if at a
certain point in time the legal and the
Practical completely diverge now I don't
think we're at that yet I think the
Practical reality is that you're you're
going to need the consent of all people
in order to make change
um
but you know I can I completely
understand the frustrations
and
ultimately will will people I think
people will consent to a change if they
feel that the pressure within the
community as such that people demand it
for more Effective Government but I
don't I think this is very hard
you know the one of the things I learned
about this peace process is that there
are some things the British government
can really come in and
yeah
lay down a solution but there are some
things that are really going to depend
on the parties themselves reaching an
agreement and you can do a certain
amount of facilitation but what you
can't do is just order people because
they they
the reality is still I think that if any
substantial part of the community
disagrees with a change to the Good
Friday agreement I think it's going to
be very hard to get it done
future thank you yes just to develop on
on Stephen's Point
um we've had some evidence about whether
or not the the the designations of first
Minister Deputy first Minister should be
just changed to call them joint first
Minister now you know it sounds cosmetic
on on one reading of it but it might
sort of open up a deeper truth about a
one way of unblocking the process do you
think there's any Merit in looking at
that sort of change of designation well
I mean I think my view is there's
there may well be Merit in it but only
if people come to it by agreement
that's my point really I I just
my experience with this is that
if a substantial part of either unionist
or nationalist opinion is opposed to
something it's very hard to do it
so if
if they can come together and agree A
Way Forward
now you know I totally get the point
that Steve was making the the sense you
then say well they've got a veto over it
but yeah yeah I think for the moment I
think the reality is
without that agreement it's hard to to
think of how it can work but
you know one of the reasons why in the
end
the executor did get up and running just
before I left office and that
extraordinary
you know meeting with Mark McGinnis and
Ian Paisley sitting together on the
you know on the on the city
getting on well together to all
appearances and
even when the cameras
weren't there
appeared to be quite genuine actually
um
but one of the reasons was that they
were
they were both prepared to really make
it work and so they had a with all of
these these different elements within
the the
agreement
there is a form and there's a spirit
and one of the things that again you
learn over time is that the form doesn't
work without the spirit right the spirit
has got to be one where people genuinely
are trying to make the thing work if if
that exists by the way you can even
evolve the form
but it's got to be people have got to
decide in Northern Ireland that that's
what they want to do and they want to
find a way forward
um and you know it never happens without
leaders being prepared to lead and this
is honestly it's so important to
emphasize this point this would never
have happened and the difference between
this peace process and many others
around the world is that we have the
benefit at that time of leaders who were
prepared to lead and if they hadn't been
prepared to do that
and to have you know I used to have very
Frank open conversations with unionists
Leaders with Republican and nationalist
leaders where
we had the ability to sit down and
strategize together they would say look
here's my problem
you're gonna have to help me find a way
around it
and I might be able to help them find a
way around it but I could only do that
because they were prepared
carry in the end to carry the burden
themselves to get it over the line
and if you're not if you don't have
people prepared to do that it's never
going to work none of these things will
ever work and and it's very difficult
because the simplest thing always to do
as a leader a very political party
as I say is just to get the round of
applause I mean it's the easiest thing
in politics to do and and in the end you
know it's what a lot of leaders do but
if they actually want to make the change
they're going to have to find the way
pulling their people behind them then
that's the difference between leading
and following
can I you cut me off about on the runs I
know I was trying to make
Progressive
this is one of the problems with the On
The Run letters was the source of the
letters because didn't appear to be a
holy independent Source in the sense
that I know we were before the psni's
creation I know there are issues about
what the communities felt about the
independence of the police and indeed
the prosecutorial authorities surely
would it would have been better for the
source of the led us not to be so
overtly political which is what they
were weren't they yeah look I think as I
said at the time you can look back at
retrospect and say you there are
elements you could have handled
differently but you were always going to
be dealt with dealing with the same
essential problem
it's just what do you do about those
those people as I say who were
not going to be charged
well I agree but but that's an
independent process should it has to be
doesn't it yeah
in retrospect it exactly it could have
been and should have been handled better
as I think we said at the time I mean
look the Hallett review went into this
and I basically think it was a pretty
fair-minded piece of work
yeah okay
on the runs letter were inappropriate
but unfortunately we're in a much worse
position now we're having Universal uh
on the run under the Legacy bill as it
stands but just just pick it up and I
agree entirely with the proposal to to
standardize the the first Minister's
title in fact I am ended up for turbot
um uh exactly that issue on a bill about
a year to go here
um but following on from your comment
that I thought was very insightful about
unionism fearing slippy slippery slopes
does it potentially mask an issue and
it's a sensitive one but do you think
unionism is psychologically ready
um to be the the marginally smaller
partner and if they aren't what does
that
um what complexion does that put on the
next couple of Decades of change that
are coming and how do you think they can
be
um assisted in getting their heads
around that
um reality well I mean
actually in my earlier comments broke
one of my my kind of rules in this
process which is never trying to offer
political parties advice
from the outside because sometimes we
can all use it
to temptation
but no I think look I think that given
the uncertainty that there is
um at the moment you know unionism wants
and needs a lot of reassurance
um
but
ultimately it will be for the unions
Community itself to you know that they
will
I think they will want to make this work
now you know I know I've seen the polls
about unionism over the protocol and
what they they agreed I mean I think
there's probably a division Within
unionism
um
well I hope because I hope that unism
can
find a way of making it work because if
if it can't then then you know Northern
Ireland would remain unstable and as I
say I personally believe that is
contrary to the pest interest of the
Union
um I think we go back to
um Stephen Ferry do we notice it's been
covered you're covered together fine
Claire North San Francisco thank you
very much what's your assessment of of
um strand to
um South dimensions and thinking back to
1998 do you think neon Union is
nationalists in particular would have
signed up to the agreement without
strand too because bear in mind they
don't have a strand to it it doesn't
exist at the moment
functioning no I mean it's time to
strands two and three were vital parts
of the agreement absolutely no doubt
about that and we wouldn't have had an
agreement without it
and
um
and that was a perfectly proper and
correct recognition of nationalists in
aspiration
um I think
that that I mean it was again an
inevitable part of the agreement
so I'm not saying it should have been
changed but it's unfortunate
that's trying to can't operate unless
strand one is operating
but that was the reality of the
situation
um and I do think
I mean I did put a certain emphasis on
strand two and strand three and was was
active and used to attend some of those
meetings and I do think
particularly over these last few years
we could have been doing more to to
activate those and make them a forum in
which the British and Irish governments
could have tried to work out a way
through things I mean I can't emphasize
enough that that
enormous role played in the whole of
this process by having
um an Irish government that was
basically always looking to be
constructive
I mean it really was a it was a great
blessing and people forget that you know
British Irish relations were you know
pretty horrible for quite a long period
of time in the past but they
you know I
you know I've always paid tribute to to
bertia Hernan and his leadership I found
a very very good person to work with and
his whole system you know his people
they were you know you could have
completely Frank conversations with them
you could have private conversations
with them and then you know a whole
series of things float from that
culminating in the in the Queen's visit
to to Ireland which is a great event and
you know always again my my view was
the the best thing in the interest of
everybody is that the British and Irish
governments had a good relationship
because that also it it it gave people
comfort
that there was there was an attempt
always to steer this process in a
constructive way and I think we should
have done
more in these last years now it looks to
me as if the relationship between the
present pm and the Irish t-shirt is is
much improved and better and that's good
it's very important a very important
relationship
um and and you know we're
even though public violence in the
European Union we're out of it
nonetheless there's a massive things we
have in common and in an interest we
share of we should be working together
and I'm not done and absolutely
um strong two and three are of huge and
unequal significance there's no attempt
to create a hierarchy it's just a matter
of fact that strand 2 is currently
hostage and and and isn't operating at
strand three years do you have any um
thoughts or advice for us on on on ways
to enhance round two and three as is a
core part of the inquiry we're doing at
the moment
I think the best thing is the UK
government takes both of those two
things really seriously and and
you know gets into the right
the right relationship and and look it
to to those strands which is I think
much more should be much more active
that that would be my my advice it's
only it's it's it's a decision the
government's got to to to take it's got
to do it very conscious of unionist
feeling but in the end it is going to be
important for us to have that
um to have that means of trying to
resolve some of these questions because
by the way as you go forward
that are going to be difficulties I
think instead there's going to be a real
difficulty
over the um the EU laws
now propose the the is it the retained
there are areas of cooperation that are
not covered by the protocol
uh that is going to cause a lot of
difficulty and it's going to be
important to keep a good relationship
with the Irish government because I know
from my own conversations in the last
two or three years
with the European Union both at a
leadership level and at a commission
level
that they will pay a lot of attention to
what the Irish government are advising
them about this situation so it's it's
just in the interests of the British
government and the interests of the
Union that you keep close relationship
with the Irish government and with its
leadership
I I agree entirely I think the
relationship is core and this is what it
structures come come after and one final
uh question from me and it's um much
further down the line with many fences
to jump um before this but um thinking
about the criteria for a border poll in
the event
um of future constitutional change I
take no issue with it not being nailed
down in 1998 and as I say
um we're not there yet but I think there
is a dynamic in the relationship have
you have you given any thought to what
you think would be the appropriate
signals or triggers
um to to test
um opinion on constitutional change
of
given thought to it and decided it's
absolutely not an issue for me to
engage in I mean there's a provision set
out in the in the agreement that's
actually quite clear was very carefully
drafted very very carefully drafted at
the time
um and did you see it as one of those
things that um one will know when one
knows but you need to write down what
would help you to know
yeah but I think this is best
left for
another time and in line with the
provisions in the agreement it's um
you know it's a subject of huge
sensitivity and it's
I don't it's probably not very helpful
for me to
patent on it but I do think it's just
worth pointing out that the structure of
it has set out in the agreement
you know when I've been rereading this
agreement to come before the committee
you know there are certain lines that
that
trigger
memories of long and protracted
negotiation and uh
you know obviously one very sensitive
issue is around that but the way it's
set out here is the right way to proceed
and it should be for the people at the
time to
fair enough you forgive me for having a
crack at it thank you I was you I would
do the same but if I was me I'd also did
the same
um you you touched on there with Miss
Hannah they uh hang their Irish
relations which are I think important
and possibly with the view to Dublin
acting as a engage Bridgehead if you
will into the European Union as the dust
starts to settle you obviously talk to
politicians and others North and South
of the Border
I think broadly our assessment as a
committee is that from a very low point
in fairly recent time anglo-irish
relations are on the improving
trajectory there seems to be good
relations and Chemistry Between the
t-shock and the prime minister so on and
so forth and I think everybody
recognizes the beneficial importance of
that
um do you have a word or two what what's
your assessment sort of overlooking the
the piece I suppose from 97 to today
what would you see as ways of improving
if indeed improvements were hard
well one of the things you learned about
the the leadership level is there's just
no substitute for personal interaction
and for sitting down and and and sharing
that you have mutual respect and
understanding of the other person's
politics I mean the worst thing when
you're a leader dealing with another
leader is is
not to show understanding of their
politics but keep talking about yours
because everyone's got their own
politics and they're often in diametric
opposition to each other and what
leaders expect you to be able to do is
to is to understand that and not
grandstand around your own politics when
you know the other person is politics in
the opposite direction so the essence is
to establish a relationship where you're
able to say look okay let's work this
out together see how we we
find a way through without giving
either of us a political problem that we
we can't handle and look that the
European Union in the end is they they
want to make this work you know they're
they're
you know I know the senior people in the
European leadership that people
who who actually have a respect for the
UK even though they regret the decision
to to leave the European Union and they
regard you know the Northern Ireland
peace process one of the the successes
within the European Space over the last
quarter of a century so they want to
protect it
I mean if if we if we don't engage in
irresponsible politics but we're we
engage in sensible and responsible
politics we can we can make it all work
I don't I don't have any doubt about
that because there's a lot of good will
and you know the other thing to
emphasize is that the
Republic of Ireland itself is a
transformed country
oh totally different to how it was yeah
25 30 years ago you know you only have
to look at the person of the tea shop
today to realize that okay it's a
changed country and it's a actually a
dynamic country today
um and you know when I was growing up it
was frankly not considered like that at
all
but now it is
and and therefore and it's a successful
member of the the European Union and so
you know
the Republic in my view
they also have an interest in stability
and they don't want to create a
situation in which you you send a great
Tremor of uncertainty through the
existing Arrangements because in the end
they're busy
doing well
creating success and and they you know
provided the Border remains open and the
interaction between Northern Ireland and
the Republic is is good economically and
socially and politically they're you
know they're they're content with it
okay
I think by their own admission the
European Union and indeed the
commissions
um understanding of the sensitivities
and concerns of political and societal
unionism
has developed
um very considerably over the last 18
months to two years as issues
surrounding the protocol have been
looked at
and hopefully that is that will give
heart to a section of the community of
Northern Ireland which we all recognize
is and as your earlier remarks have
indicated it's important to carry as
many people as possible and to make sure
that both sides are are broadly happy
happy then certainly not Furious
do you have a concern that
um obviously the road of Washington
is is very important as we know in the
dimension of Irish politics and indeed
angular Irish politics
does the same piece of work need to be
done in Washington given the sometimes
fair and sometimes unfair
characterization that the White House
irrespective of who is the occupant of
it
is
um
less well-read up let me put it that way
on unionism its Traditions its concerns
the Integrity of the UK and we've got
this hugely welcome visit of President
Biden I think President Clinton and Mrs
Clinton are intending to visit as well
which will be a huge Philip and we'll
put the Eyes of the world once again
back onto the island of Ireland and the
importance of the Good Friday good but
is that is that a concern
so my experience
I mean first of all this President by
the way is
you know deeply committed to Ireland and
and and actually does know a lot about
its history and
the situation there today and I I found
I mean President Clinton was immensely
helpful over the negotiation of the of
the Good Friday Belfast agreement
um President Bush actually visited a
school in Northern Ireland I think in
the course of his time and again was was
very supportive of the process so
my view of of the American
Administration on on this issue is if
the UK government looks as if it's in
the saddle
writing forward knows where it's going
and what it's doing they'll just get
behind it
and so I think this is why the
negotiation of the of the agreement
around the protocol has been important
and it's it's important also to say
about that because I I didn't say this
when I was talking about it earlier
I mean I have looked at in detail at the
um
the The Windsor agreement and
the truth is number one
there is
an acceptance on both the EU side and
the and the UK side
to find practical ways through
and both have shown flexibility to do
that the Europeans have shown up quite a
lot of flexibility compared with what
they could have done if they just
decided to take a dogmatic position they
haven't
but secondly what
the negotiated changes that the prime
minister is this prime minister has has
done
having my view substantially narrowed
the potential for conflict to arise of a
constitutional sort so I think to be
fair this is why I think when people
look at it you're okay you can argue
about
the degree to which the ecj is still
involved in certain aspects but the
truth is
along with that storm and break you the
the actual in substance terms
the issues are substantially resolved
and that's why I I hope people do give
it
give it support but it's and therefore
that's why I think for the American
Administration what they will think is
look if the UK government is
you know it's back with the clear
direction that then we will want to
support it and the other thing is which
I think has been of assistance over the
years but I know that
this this President is interested in is
what America can do for the Northern
Ireland economy yes and and that will
also be important
um Robin Walker and then
you put a great emphasis and I think
understandably given um how the
agreements were reached on the
interpersonal relationships and the
Trust on them one-on-one
um level that's been built as part of
races clearly part of the genius of the
agreement itself is the the interlinking
of the different strands and and
um the uh the role of the balance
between strand two is granted three in
that respect
do you think it's a matter of regret
that fewer of your successes as prime
ministers have taken part directly in
the British Irish Council and and do you
think that you I know you don't agree
with advice to political parties but
would your advice in general be for
um Prime Ministers of the United Kingdom
to take a personal and direct engagement
in that
yes and I think
particularly now it's important
um look I understand when the I mean one
of the benefits of when something ceases
to be a big issue it's it stops coming
across the the Prime Minister zesk and
you've always got a thousand other
issues to deal with and in a way it's
what you want is to be able to spend
less time on one issue than another but
I think
um
right now particularly
as we see this
protocol and how it works over the next
years I think the relationship between
the British and Irish government will be
very important
and and sorry I was just saying and and
surely that's the case given that those
ad hoc site conversations used to take
place at cancer The View uh you know um
commission meetings and everything else
are not taking place they make those
sort of formal bilaterals actually key
that's a very good point because
obviously when we were in the European
Union European Council meetings you're
constantly interacting with people
anyway but we're not now so yeah makes
it even more important at least and just
just to add to that the broader issue of
interpersonal relationships and Trust I
mean one of the institutions that helped
build trust in the run-up for Good
Friday even before your time as prime
minister was the British Irish
parliamentary assembly do you think
there are opportunities to look at the
structure of that and to broaden its
reach in terms of what that could do to
build trust and understanding
um between UK parliamentarians and their
counterparts in mid oil and and indeed
in Northern Ireland yeah I think it's
always good for people to
to talk with each other so that they
understand where the other people are
coming from because you know the biggest
risks with with the process like this is
always when people
misread the politics of the situation
and then try and do something that's
going to be hugely disruptive so the
more
individual members of the doyle or the
UK parliament are talking to each other
and interacting with each other the
better it will be
caller thank
you to touch on on something you talked
about earlier about some recent polling
and you will be aware of the the Lucid
pool uh show that only 35 percent of
unionists would actually vote Yes the
Belfast agreement with a 54 percent
voting no if the vote was to take place
again
um in your opinion why do you think
unionists have really moved away from
support for the Belfast agreement
um
well
one of the difficult because I think you
were saying is 54 are against and 35 in
favor yeah
so
it's
if you're political leadership is
giving a message that this is bad
you know your support will often
consider it to be bad so I think it's
not just a question of of what people
kind of think objectively but also where
they're they're LED but I understand
unionism
will always feel
that it's
um that it's at risk to some degree I
mean
how how could you not because of the
circumstances of the situation in
exactly the same way that I think
unionism
will always
be in part distrustful of the UK
government
I think you know that that's my
experience well of course and you will
always say there's good reason for it
but you know going back to Margaret
Thatcher's time no the anger Irish
agreement yeah he was going to think of
the John major star I don't think
there's never going to be a situation
where there isn't
that distrust but I
that's why I come back to the question
of strategy and Leadership
that it is important to work out and
that's why I said to you I'm I'm a union
it's not in order to to you know to make
some great political statement my own
belief but to say to explain where I was
coming from the first speech I made as
prime minister the first
um in 1997 was to an essentially
unionist audience in Northern Ireland
when I became labor leader much to a
part of my party's dismayed by the way I
moved us out of arguing for a United
Ireland and said no if we want to reach
an agreement we've got to be objective
about it the question is always
what is the best way
to achieve your objective and all I'm
saying is I think when you look at it
strategically right now in my view the
best way for unionism to secure its
future
is for it to stabilize the situation in
Northern Ireland now of course you
shouldn't do that if it's if it's in
defiance or undermining basic principles
but I think that this Windsor agreement
because it's essentially a practical way
of squaring a circle is that it is a way
that you can legitimately get the best
of both worlds which is what in a sense
Northern Ireland wants to do and then to
move on and I think you know yes you
know of course what why do I think
unionism is is anxious about it
I think it was always anxious about the
Good Friday agreement you know your
party obviously opposed the agreement at
the beginning it came to come into
government but it's always going to be
worried because it's going to think our
our position within the UK is somehow at
risk think the disagreement between us
is how you best secure the union because
my view is you best secure it
by
making the status quo work and you know
I remember having a conversation with
one of your colleagues early on in the
process after the Good Friday agreement
and and
he said to me what have we got out of
this agreement and I said you've got the
Union
because For the First Time
everyone's going to accept the principle
of consent so everything else is a
question of
of of how you get the right political
strategy to advance this course so I
understand the concerns honestly I don't
diminish them at all that's why at an
earlier stage around the protocol I said
the European Union should be flexible
try and take account of the
sensitivities but I honestly believe the
best thing forward now is to get back
into a stable form of government
thank you
um I have an eye on the time we we
certainly finished at 11. it has just
chined 11 o'clock on behalf of the
committee can I thank you for your
attendance this morning for taking a
wide range of questions from the full
range of opinion and I suppose as
somebody who first stood for our
election along with
um Robert Buckland back in 1997.
um you were successful and we weren't
but for what it's worth and I thank you
for completing the mission that
Gladstone set himself which was to
finally pacify Island thank you order
order thank you